[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture tout de suite le
sommaire
exposition réenchanter la ville perd
cependant in situ peinture ou encore
rétrospective photographique
une vingtaine d'artistes ont investi les
800 mètres carrés de l'ancienne poste
centrale 2 versailles retour sur la
présentation de la saison culturelle aux
clayes-sous-bois un programme qui
tournera autour de trois thèmes molière
les femmes et le swing l'occasion de
lancer la nouvelle exposition arts
numériques et puis le spectacle please
stand-up sera visite ce week-end une
représentation humoristique 100%
féminine présenté par marine bas où son
celi agathe son goût ce serait avec nous
pour en parler
je vous le dis en titre le collectif
qu'est 36 a dévoilé son exposition
réenchanter la ville jeudi dernier une
vingtaine d'artistes ont collaboré au
projet fresques sculptures ou encore
photographie jusqu'au 18 octobre
l'ancienne poste de versailles deviendra
un lieu d'exposition atypique reportage
d'astrid bergère l'ancienne fosse
centrale de versailles devient pendant
un mois un lieu d'expériences
artistiques urbaines à mi chemin entre
galeries et expositions la maison de
production qu'à 36 a réuni une vingtaine
d'artistes pour faire vivre ce lieu
inoccupé et trois espaces s'y
distinguent
ja
un regard sur qui nous sommes et 36 de
manière de vrai dans l'est dans les
villes et dans l'espace public et
ensuite un espace qui est dédié à au
quartier bernard de jussieu pour donner
à voir ce qui est en train de se
construire et d'advenir et ensuite vous
avez au global une vingtaine d'artistes
qui sont venus intervenir à la fois
qu'il est pire y sont présents ici à la
fois à travers des oeuvres sur toile via
de l'install la sculpture la
lithographie depuis le mois d'avril 2010
9 des fresques murales sur le thème de
la vigne nature sont réalisés dans le
quartier bernard de jussieu de
nombreuses rénovations thermiques ont
été faites dans les immeubles de ce
quartier et le but est d'en cueillir des
mûres pignan qu'à 36 nous a fait
connaître des artistes venus du monde
entier et il y à aujourd'hui et nos
fraises qui ont été réalisés qui sera là
spectacle pour francine sortes de
collections d'art contemporain qui est
fait aujourd'hui dans ce quartier
versailles tente aujourd'hui de faire un
parallèle entre les différents arrêts de
mettre en avant le freeski sme et le
muralisme cette exposition ici qui est
une vision va dire plus contemporaines
de l'art urbain qui est avec des
artistes vraiment grands talents venus
un peu du monde entier dans une ville
histoire comme versailles c'est
intéressant justement de dire que la
création elle continuera t nième siècle
et parmi les autres expositions à venir
dans le département françoise pétrovitch
présente habiter la villa elle sera
visible à la villa savoye jusqu'au 24
janvier 2021
une quinzaine de peintures et de
sculptures sont à découvrir
le conservatoire des arts de montigny le
bretonneux accueille l'exposition face
au rythme des tableaux a observé
jusqu'au 14 octobre pour ses peintures
l'artiste s'est inspiré de cultures
anciennes
enfin le château de breteuil a ouvert
c'est mal c'est mal ce week end une
vingtaine de costumes et robes de
famille est dévoilée à cette occasion
la collection sera visible jusqu'au 1er
novembre
bien que particulière à cause de la
crise sanitaire
la villa des clayes-sous-bois a maintenu
la soirée de présentation de la saison
culturelle 2020 2021
au programme une soirée originale et le
vernissage de l'exposition arts
numériques
un reportage d'eléonore sinoquet molière
les femmes ou encore le swing voici les
grandes lignes de la saison culturelle
2020-2021 aux clayes sous bois
elle a été lancée en grande pompe samedi
19 septembre à l'espace philippe noiret
au programme de cette année de l'humour
du théâtre de l'art vivant ou encore des
concerts cabaret une saison qui
s'annonce éclectique et chargé malgré
lakovic 19
l'enjeu il est multiple puisque il faut
déjà pas perdre notre public
le public existant et fidèles qu'on à
chaque année lui permettre de pouvoir
revenir dans les meilleures conditions
qui soient
malgré les contraintes sanitaires est
toujours le même enjeu c'est faire venir
le public qui ne se permet pas dans
encore de venir dans les salles de
spectacles en plus d'une présentation
originale de la saison culturelle la
municipalité a profité de cette soirée
pour inaugurer l'exposition arts
numériques de l'artiste nouvelle manque
lycienne maaf l'eau et passe-droits
entre art et science
il n'y a qu'un pas on désire en fait
c'est de faire vivre des de l'émotion de
faire voir les choses autrement de
questionner nos relations nos
perceptions de nos environnements
changer un peu la vision des choses par
le biais de ma vision à moi qui ai
souvent oniriques
c'est vraiment utiliser des outils
technologiques sommes vraiment des
outils pour créer de la magie
et mettre en mouvement en fait des
objets des images faire intervenir le
sont donc on retrouve tout ça au coeur
de l'installation sous forme un petit
peu de cabinets de curiosité et pour
mieux appréhender lèvres de ma flow est
pas doué
son exposition est à découvrir à
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois jusqu'au 20 octobre
et parmi les spectacles proposés aux
clayes-sous-bois please stand-up pour ce
plateau 100 % féminin quatre humoristes
vont se produire sur la scène de
l'espace philippe noiret vendredi 2
octobre à 20h30
et pour parler de ce spectacle ce soir
celle yaga tsongo bonsoir à l'oscar
alors expliquez nous pourquoi c'est
votre coup de coeur de la saison
culturelle et bien parce que c'est une
heure trente à deux heures de rires non
stop
et si je ne connais pas bien la durée
c'est parce que ce sont 4 one woman show
81,8 the one woman show 24 femmes qui
aiment l'improvisation et donc ça peut
durer plus longtemps que prévu
alors ça fait un peu plus d'un an
qu'elles sont en tournée maintenant et
la metteur en scène nous explique
pourquoi ça marche
elles ont toutes chacune vraiment des
individus à l'éco hyper intéressant on
passe un moment hyper fun parce que
parce que justement ces deux univers qui
sont complètement différents qui se
marient complètement les uns avec les
autres et surtout qu'ils sont très forts
que des jumeaux réaction très drôle et
elle joue super bien à l'écrit super
bien et j'ai cru comprendre qu'en plus
de leur plume elles ont aussi tout une
personnalité bien à elle oui alors elles
sont plus ou moins connus du grand
public mais elles ont toutes deux
l'expérience
par exemple nous avons rencontré
christine berrou lors d'un set 8 humour
aujourd'hui suis toujours végétariens et
puis avec ma mère on s'engueulait à noël
parce que je ne voulais pas manger la
dinde qu'elle avait préparés alors du
coup elle a essayé de ruse et elle m'a
dit comme ça non mais j'ai dit aux
bouchers que tu voulais plus faire
souffrir les animaux
alors du coup il m'a donné une dinde
dépressive
laura aux dommages très présente sur les
réseaux sociaux enchaîne les personnages
déjantés
parce que quand tu es un animal ça va tu
devrais un chat par exemple il a passé
de bichat accrocha ce bâtard
j'avais de la clé quant à anaïs eux
tempère le breton elle se focalise sur
un seul personnage celui d'une femme
dans une entreprise et marine bas où
sont elles c'est la présentatrice de ce
spectacle moi mon travail je le vois
vraiment comme ça c'est de chauffer la
salle et de chauffer les gens pour
qu'ils soient prêts à recevoir avec le
plus d'énergie possible et le plus de
disponibilité aussi les artistes qui
vont passer derrière moi pis stand up
s'inscrit dans des thématiques actuelles
les quatre humoristes parle
essentiellement de moments de vie et pas
forcément de thèmes propres aux femmes
nous savons en a marre d'entendre qu'il
n'y a pas de femmes humoristes et que et
que toute façon des humoristes femmes
sont moins drôle que les hommes étaient
de mythes qui est que les femmes parlent
de choses de femmes etc les hommes c'est
universel etc faut en fait
rendez-vous donc vendredi 2 octobre à
20h30 tous masqués bien entendu pour
découvrir ou redécouvrir ces quatre
talents et puis bah profitez-en puisque
c'est la seule date du département super
bien merci seigneur nous avoir éclairé
sur ce spectacle on retrouve la semaine
prochaine dans le prochain 7,8 culture
avec plaisir ils sont sept comédiens
chanteurs à venir présenter leur
spectacle humoristique musicale et
carnets de notes la compagnie sans souci
donnera deux représentations le samedi 3
octobre à 18 heures puis à 20h30
elles auront lieu à la maison de
l'environnement des sciences et du
développement durable de magny les
hameaux
le spectacle est sur le thème de l'école
marie line gourdon devons nous en parle
juste après un extrait du spectacle
de la tête devant nous
[Musique]
on a raconté les joies de la cantine de
la cour de récré des interros surprise
en classe on a parlé on parle de pleins
pleins d'autres choses
[Musique]
c'est un vrai bonheur qui s'y retrouvent
qu'ils henry qu'ils ampleur et que c'est
tout à fait à l'image de ce qu'ils
vivent et que c'est un bel hommage à à
ce métier d'enseignant qui sont des
passeurs qui sont des transmetteurs et
qu'on les voit pas souvent comme ça
alors que je pense que il ya beaucoup
beaucoup vous prisé prix d'enseignants
de professeurs qui sont très engagés
dans une structure qui aime profondément
les enfants un spectacle qui se voit en
famille tout seul en groupe avec des
copains parce que c'est rôle parce qu'on
s'y reconnaît pas ce que je tente et
donc il ya des émotions et d aider d une
énergie qui se dégage tellement forte
que les gens qui viennent passent une
soirée incroyable
nous on s'amuse follement son plateau on
est sept hauts plateaux les instruments
sont en direct il ya des guitares du
violoncelle du ukulélé du du mélodica
c'est extrêmement riche
c'est drôle ça déconne partout un
casting pour découvrir de jeunes talents
les bénévoles de la croupe de la troupe
nymag sont à la recherche d'enfants
entre 10 et 14 ans pour participer à
leur première comédie musicale
jérôme rita d'eau nous en dit plus je
pense que l'amour du spectacle chez les
enfants en vie il importe leurs
capacités si ils ont vraiment envie on
arrivera nous à les former et à aller
mettre à les mettre en scène avec leurs
propres capacités web demande d'avoir
des enfants qui jeu forcément danser
chanter jouer la comédie et je pense que
tout ça prend voilà il y en a une petite
année pour mettre en place
et puis leur faire vivre un rêve quoi
simplement que les emmenant tournée et
espère participer à des émissions de
télé et à des événements des live puis à
l'enregistrement d'un single aussi
le casting aura lieu le samedi 27
septembre de 14 heures à 18 heures il se
déroulera à la maison de quartier vauban
à versailles pour les participants il
faudra se munir d'une clé usb et d'une
chanson à présenter inscription via le
mail qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
l'auteur et interprète scala a sorti son
nouveau clip au mois d'août
originaire des yvelines le chanteur
présente gay à eau
le titre en featuring avec l'unique
grillot a déjà récolté plus de 30000
vues sur youtube
objectif faire découvrir l'afrique
l'artiste nous présente son nouveau clip
avec cet extrait on met pas la famille
je vous hais par mer c'est le revoir mes
graphiques pour mais surtout et puis les
enfants courent deux pas
et ouais je nous ai parlé avant
paris des malheurs
ouais
là
pas du tout
mais là
c'est la fin de ce numéro du 7-8 culture
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour de nouvelles
asie des deux sorties culturelles dont
le département
et d'ici là portez vous bien
[Musique]